[Music]
brittany is in knoxville hi brittany how
are you
i'm doing well how are y'all better than
we deserve what's up
so i am on baby steps 3d saving for a
down payment on our house
um i'm currently a nurse that i work
monday through friday so i'm trying to
figure out a side hustle where i can
make some extra money to eventually pay
off the house early
and i'm wondering if it would be a good
idea for me to start
a photography business on the side
are you any good at photography
i've not really had much practice and
currently i don't
actually have a camera i've been wanting
to play around with my moms
a little bit but so why photography then
i i've always liked
photography itself i like the idea of
helping families make memories that sort
of thing
and i know when we took my senior
pictures with my aunt just
coming up with poses and stuff i had a
lot of fun with that
okay and your mom's camera is what what
is
is it a good enough camera to take some
pictures with to get started
i'm not sure it i think she got it in
like 2013
so it's a with a decent camera then but
it's pretty outdated
i would also definitely need a laptop
because my
laptop from college is shot it doesn't
really work anymore
and is your goal brittany to generate
extra income or are you trying to start
uh extra income to pay off debt are you
trying to get extra income to
you know just because you want to have
another hobby a side business
i would like to um
like i said i'm on baby step 3b so i
want to save up for down payment and
then
my goal is to eventually i'm 23.
uh i'm single i want to have a paid for
house by the time i have kids eventually
good so what do you mean so i can stay
home yeah
what do you make i make about 55 000 and
what do you want to spend on a camera
and laptop
uh it would be probably for that and
like some sd cards and stuff my budget
would be 2 000.
okay and so if you take two thousand
dollars in the middle of the table and
and light it on fire for a hobby it does
not keep you from hitting your goals
okay and so that's like your worst case
scenario
in other words you buy these things and
it never amounts to squat you don't make
any money
but you got a nice camera and you got a
nice laptop and you just did this for a
hobby
and you spent some of your house money
to do that or some of your income money
to do that
you see what i'm saying yes now if you
told me it's 20 000 i would say no
right yeah right because as a ratio in
your world that's two stinking much
money to burn
yeah if you make 500 000 a year and you
want to burn 20 000 we'll talk about it
but you see what i'm doing i mean we're
just saying does this keep you
from hitting your goals by the time
you're 30 no it does not
and so it's okay it's okay at that
budget amount to give this a try
um i i will tell you that
um from a business only perspective what
i think you ought to do is you ought to
check out uh christy wright and business
boutique oh just about to say
and begin to think about how we're
looking at this um
this sounds like something you you
thought about over coffee and prayer one
morning and you've actually never done
it
at all and all of a sudden now you're
opening a business doing it
that's a that's a bit of a leap yeah and
so i would rather you
um you know before we actually set up
shop i'd rather you just go around and
get some confirmation from people that
you actually have an
eye through that lens to and some people
go wow i really like those shots and
maybe somebody would pay for that you
know or
you know or people go yeah
maybe you shouldn't do this and do some
research on it too
um you know youtube is very good uh if
you're gonna buy a camera
i would definitely jump on youtube and
see what's the best camera out there in
your budget
people are doing reviews all the time
set your budget
and it'd be very clear and then you say
hey best camera under
500 bucks you're going to find a lot of
cameras uh that people are saying here's
here
here's the good things but i definitely
will say sit back and ask yourself
you know uh am i doing this because i
really want to become a photographer
or am i doing this just because and if
you're trying to save money to buy a
house you can go drive for uber
you know if it's a temporary fix because
i don't see you making a lot of money
that quick
on something you've never done before
but if you pick up an uber job a
delivering pizza delivering uh groceries
picking up people groceries you can make
money instantly
so i don't think yeah i i kind of had
the feeling this is i agree with you but
i kind of the where i went on it was
it's more about scratching an itch than
it was
actually i got you didn't make your
money i got you and so it's quasi-hobby
that might turn into some money i got
you
and i and if that's the case if if it
does turn into money we'll call that
wonderful
yes you know but uh you know what's how
many pictures you gotta take to get your
two thousand dollars back
a lot yeah depending on i mean
as a beginner photographer a lot and a
lot of time because you know she got to
get her skills up yeah